and in the end all the blood sweat and
tears that went into the deal-making the
writing the rewriting the casting the
costumes the sets the directing the
acting the editing the Tantrums the
phone calls faxes emails lunches dinners
press junkets handshaking back-slapping
cajoling and advertising it all boils
down to five films nominated for Best
Picture the nominees are
Chocolat David Brown Kitt's golden and
Leslie Halloran producers
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon bill Kong
silly Kong and Angley producers Erin
Brockovich Danny DeVito Michael
Schamberg and Stacey shear producers
ladee ater Douglas wick David friends
Oni and Branko Lustig producers
traffic edward zwick marshall husky wits
and laura Bickford producers
and the Oscar goes to gladiator
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination for Douglas Wieck it
is David Franz oneis first Oscar and
second nomination receive me for
gladiator
this is Branko Lustig second Oscar he
won an Academy Award
three four Schindler's List
takes a lot of people to make a Coliseum
but only takes one or two to mess it up
to all the wizards who brought to life
the sights sounds and citizens of a
faraway world we should take a chisel to
this statue and give you your fair share
but instead I hope you will accept our
thanks for not messing it up David Franz
Oni great dreaming walter parks and
laurie macdonald you swooped in on your
chariot and ran over everything and
everybody in your way
Ridley Scott you invaded three
continents with your tireless
perfectionism and brought and brought
Ridley and you brought new meaning to
the phrase mad dogs and Englishmen in
the noonday Sun Bill Nicholson and John
Logan you saved our flank Russell Crowe
you filled a whole arena with a force of
your face and put the human back in the
hero Stacy Schneider Ronnie Mayer
Jeffrey Katzenberg Steven Spielberg
Terry press in those early days where it
looked like all roads might lead not to
roam but to ruin you were gladiators
Sarah Julia Tessa Lucy for me all roads
lead to you thanking all the same people
Doug thanked but that gentleman genius
Ridley Scott who transported us back
thousands of years in time so
effortlessly and beautifully thank you
really
Russell walking everyone thank you so
much my wife Nancy my son Hudson my
dearly departed dad who was the greatest
storyteller who ever lived
I'm sure is unhide Oliver Reed right now
throwing back some of the dark stuff
then enjoying the hell out of this thank
you thank you to everybody who made this
movie together with us Thank You Ridley
thank you for the honor to work with you
and take to everybody in the
international big crew all around the
world they helped us to do it strength
and honor